yo tout le monde sait squeeze
aujourd'hui on se trouve donc pas sur un
jeu mais sur un logiciel qu'un abonné
m'a conseillé en me disant qu'ils
étaient super marrant et c'était un
super étrange fait riga voilà c'est la
première fois que je n'en serais plus qu
et déjà j'ai ouvert mon double est vieux
c'était trop bien fait en fait là on et
rocket raccoon du garden la galaxie quoi
mais sans aucune arme finalement on est
un simple [ __ ] laveur banal je sais pas
ce qu'il est en train d'apprécier vais
peut-être la politique et si on tente de
faire le [ __ ] laveur psychopathe
ah ah ah ok il fait carrément peur il ya
d'autres personnes ou pas du tout piqué
ne pipe mot nous la regardons ça c'est
moi c'était horrible à 1 1
alia qu'italien oui bonsoir je suis une
gente dame de la noblesse ça ab elle
n'est pas descendue boîte
salut je veux tout séduit c'est bien
comme ça je sais pas trop ce qui
m'arrive
oh il nous a fait un regard là et nous a
charmés vous peut le dire à temps à la
défense entre le défaut et customiser
ses customiser super triste quoi bonsoir
je suis à lyon je suis belle bonsoir je
suis à lyon je suis morte
moi c'est les recettes écran forcé de
faire les mêmes expressions de visage
que celui qui utilise le logiciel de
merde hein tu parle de moi là ouais
suivant va isoler à dragon métier rêve
d'être à drago c'est juste impossible et
attend et tir à longue les hommes et non
what's up cathy au rocket raccoon
version femme elle est carrément stylet
mais on a envie d ordre regardez est-ce
que là vous n'avez pas envie de la lah
seul coup comme ça et qu'elle fasse ça
bon s comme ça joue mon rôle je
m'appelle cathy rocket raccoon a
toujours rêvé de moi car et c'est moi le
court s'il vous plaît bon il est clair
que quand tu joues à se jeter
schizophrénie se développe
moi c'est cathy de 60 ans je m'habille
comme ça et de temps en temps comme ça
mais en fait si je la couleur qui change
puisque en fait j'ai que trois tenues
que sont les mêmes c'est peut-être pour
ça que les pas de copains alors là j'ai
toujours rêvé d'être viril comme ça je
suis le commandant chasseurs et si je
louche
moi je pouvais pas voir ta marché ou
penser nous allons partir au starbucks
la guerre c'est fini les amphores voilà
c'était mal répartie de commandant au
salut voyez rocket raccoon star à ton
labeur moi je suis un chien ou alou ou
je ne sais pas ce que je suis
dany un truc qui me trouble ses joues
mais calmement un vrai arcs de cercles
par jour et là à tamba en fait c'est de
m'être bien profil comme ça regardez la
longueur du museau quoi une trompe
cette année la trompe en fait tu attends
tu moque de moi la wii comme un chien
sur son expression du visage en une
seconde ils peuvent passer de l'animal
le plus miné au monde à l'animal le plus
terrifiant du monde à ça et je peux
dormir comme 90% de l'année qui est
hélas cette mèche me dérangeait pas
d'épisode kfor dont soutien gorge cette
option il est improbable quoi selphy
times minimum d'hygiène cette photo sur
facebook 1 et moi je suis une femme
plutôt joli plutôt mature finalement
j'ai de la fourrure sur ma robe
mais un énorme décolleté et ce qui fait
que médecin j'ai littéralement plus faux
avec un bonnet de noël
j'ai fait plein d'expérience et vous
allez avoir des cadeaux puisque jean
bonnet de noël en fait plus faux nos
glasses aux îles un grand front voilà
quoi sert ces lunettes à cacher son
grand front à sa cellule hier qui veut
et qui fait quand il veut draguer la
fidh de tout à l'heure on sera ensemble
elle est en ville attraper la petite
langue de jouer avec de faire ça j'ai
faim bonsoir je suis lady catherine
l'éducatrice en fait c'est carrément la
même offre que katia voilà juste elle a
une robe en futaie c'est carrément
l'opposé quoi soulager grande soit-elle
à une veste qui remonte limite au dessus
de sa tête
gore burgaud ouais tu sais quoi parce
qu'on joue un [ __ ] de hamburgers quand
même non je suis qu'un petit hamburger
innocent avec de la salade et de la
bonne source
ah ah ah ah bon je crois que je pourrais
jamais faire le rôle d'un méchant dans
un film ou même dans un dessin animé ou
même dans une vidéo youtube les sourcils
frites
tu les aides il cache mes yeux je suis
le méchant pellicule parfois mais je
prends des photos
machi je suis le chat tout voudrais pas
les coutumes achète le greffe télé tout
cas d'opel tout on chez toi mais je sens
la langue c'est ça que tu veux mon gars
tiens là voilà ça se fait plaisir ou pas
mais qui a créé sa descente huit
personnalités
voilà c'était machine bah il a dit qu'il
avait quittée et a dit ah ouais c'est
pas moi aussi intrigué je m'appelle ni
des chiens je suis originaire chanoine
et je pratique le missouri un sport
asiatiques qui permet entre autres rares
habilités de la langue
j'absorbe sonné il est là il est enfermé
dans son visage en fait il faudrait
qu'il est enfermé sous sa peau en fait
qui veut sortir mais qui n'arrive pas
super triste voilà c'est une sorte
dramatique faisant faire un livre
carrément le nez de midori chan on passe
de l'image de lui à mouazé il ya un
écart quoi et s'écarte narines et les
cas fait siennes
ça fait carrément bouger sa bouche mais
pas du tout c'est david ça pourra y
attendons à tan tan et masqués ont été
démasqués instantanément samouraï
j'ai juste le château minots de telle
heure mais je veux donner un style tu en
as marck se montrent trop mignon
schulberg hunters sans le bon gros mec
bien viril il un gosse et sa belle fille
c'est innocent qu'il avait toujours une
porte tu vois ça qu'est-ce que tu te
train de faire jackson différence entre
toi et moi c'est moi le matin tu pas
besoin de me coiffer ça je le vis
vraiment comme une attaque quoi c'est
mon petit côté artiste à qui seront
faites vos visages aux médias style et
mes frères mes soeurs en cause les
mensonges on peut pas lever ses mains il
peut tirer la langue
non je veux pas casser le mythe on
casserait un peu plus tard vous voilà
vous jeunes voyagent à voile a battu pau
bc dont je mens et on m'a dit de dire
cette phrase à chaque personne que je
vois quand je dors ma tête ressemble à
ça je dois part ça je m'appelle pas du
tout j'aime beaucoup les calories a
notamment ça suffit les bêtises je
redeviens moi même si j'ai appris cette
vidéo sur facebook
j'espère vous a plus de ces cas
n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo ça ferait
vraiment plaisir avant de balancer ou
trop je voulais juste vous dire qu'hier
soir c'était cyprien gaming show je suis
pas si vous avez regardé ou non mais
dans tous les cas sachez que c'était un
grand moment pour moi c'est la première
fois que je monte sur scène et que je
rencontre et on tourne abonnés en même
temps et ça m'a vraiment ému et j'ai
trouvé ça carrément incroyable voilà que
l'on vive ça tous ensemble que il y
avait une ambiance de fou vraiment y
avait une ambiance de fou j'étais épaté
même avant de monter sur scène déguisé
en marie-antoinette j'avais quelques
limites j'ai faim j'ai lu presque les
larmes aux yeux tellement je trouvais ça
formidable
et voilà je tenais je tenais je trouvais
que c'était important de vous remercier
pour ça parce que c'était quelque chose
d'incroyable que j'ai vécu hier soir
j'avais toujours pas blanc met je pense
qu'à ça toute la journée c'est un truc
de dingue pas bref voila merci pour tout
c'est incroyable ce que vous faites vive
et j'espère que ma game show vous aurez
bien plus en tout cas nous on a passé un
pur moment et j'espère que vous aussi
que voilà je trouvais ça important de
vous le dire parce que c'était steve
harris était juste d'arguer voilà mille
mercis on se retrouve très dense de
belles vidéos comme d'habitude tout le
monde piste
[Musique]